what i think is amazing about you bro
and this is what i encourage a lot of
people to do is
the debate is should you pursue your
passion or should you pursue money
pursue your passion or pursue money when
i was in my early 20s i couldn't give
two shits about money that's the ironic
thing that i ended up in finance and
hosting a financial show
is that i was just about pursuing my
passions i was a stand-up comedian i did
nightlife in south beach i was a
substitute teacher i worked at a sports
agency i was just doing [ __ ] that i
wanted to do
until i was like holy crap i'm sick of
living on my friend's couches let me go
get make some money and basically i
entered that
you know the financial world it took me
years to cut my teeth and you know make
it in the finance world a decade later
i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm a millionaire
this is insane i was sleeping on couches
10 years ago now i have like a
legitimate business and a legitimate
business model and then after that
happened i went back to pursuing
passions that i had i opened up a
stand-up comedy club next to bodega and
south beach called ricky's so we did
that and night life stuff with bodega
and miami if you're ever down there but
then i kind of circled back to my
passions and now i'm working on
something that i'm passionate about
which is having conversations with
people regarding what their passions are
in finance and financial wellness and
dating and relationships so ultimately
i'm giving you that that big spiel right
there
to ask you like how do you balance your
passion which is clearly animals but
also
making enough money so you can freaking
feed your animals how do you balance the
passion and the money well my whole
passion my whole life is animals you
know so i gotta make a way you know to
find out how to feed myself and feed
them and it's through animals through my
passion and you can have
thoughts of making millions of dollars
all you want you know but if you don't
have the work ethic or the
drive to want to go through whatever you
got to go through because chasing money
you're going to get to a point where
whatever the [ __ ] you're going through
just ain't worth it for the money right
you know you just don't want to go
through it anymore you want the stress
you don't want the you know the pressure
to keep going forward sometimes and if
your end goal in that situation is just
your just money you're going to break
you're always going to break if you have
a passion
something that no like you'll [ __ ]
die doing it
are you able to curse on you yeah sorry
if you're going to die doing it you can
go through your lowest point in your
life and you're just not going to give
up
and then that can turn a whole different
side of you into being hungry
disciplined
having your behavior match your finances
you know when you do get another shot
you know and then your money is going to
triple quadruple you're going to make
more money than you ever thought you're
going to make in your life if you're
chasing your passion because you have to
drive the work ethic the discipline
dedication and the durability to go
through anything
you're going to have your mountains and
your valleys and if you're going to go
through mountain valleys in life you got
to have a passion to keep you going do
you think that there's some a specific
balance that you need to have meaning
like some people are passionate about
basketball they love basketball but
they're never going to make it to the
nba so it's like at some point they need
to like all right well maybe you become
a coach or an assistant or whatever
or maybe you know like if you're i know
people in the especially in the
financial world they're just all about
the money about the money they work in
wall street they get freaking burnt out
within five seven years they're out of
it so there does need to be a balance
meaning
yes pursue something you're passionate
about but if you're not making money
doing it you need to pivot but also if
you're just focusing on the money
it's gonna like you said you're gonna
burn out because you're not passionate
about it do you think that that's like
for instance like the 80 20 rule you
need to have 80 passion 20 money is our
balance that comes to mind what do you
think i believe so you know um me i'm
just a naturally born hustler you know
so i'm gonna make a way i if i got paid
20 bucks when i was a kid for cleaning
up qriket poop
that 20 bucks is 20 million you couldn't
convince me i couldn't make a million
dollars or 100 million dollars
picking up qriket poop in the future you
know but that's just
my mindset of being a passionate person
inside my work space so passion is more
important than money for you for the
money is important for surely amber okay
i'm like i don't need much you know
right i'm an animal guy you're a
minimalist at heart would you say
freaking minimalist dude you know i have
stuff when i do have too much stuff i'm
like dog get it out of here take it i
have a lot of siblings
i'm always a 10. so i'm always giving
[ __ ] away
by the way i'm always giving [ __ ] away
if i accumulate too much stuff as
homeless before you know so i know what
it is to be like on
the other end of a lifestyle when you're
living what does it mean to be a
minimalist to you bro get rid of that
[ __ ] you know if i have 15 20 30 pairs
of shoes after a few months i'm like dog
give me five shoes [ __ ] take them
yeah you know if i got shirts in my
closet or stuff i'm accumulating over
i'm like take it get it give it away
let's give it to the home like what
about jewelry cars
really ever bought jewelry it's not it's
something you're into okay i lied
i lied i bought a couple things when i'm
traveling yeah it's like eight bucks
thirteen bucks to get but there's a
little ring or something
i would call those mementos
right i never in my life would spend
money on jewelry like gotcha unless i'm
buying a diamond for my wife for getting
married you know or presents for her i'm
not a big fan